[Music]
my entire life I've been practical I
make one romantic decision and it bit me
in the ass are you talking about work or
Gabrielle Paris oh
Emily Cooper is here to stay in Paris
yes season three of the Lily Collins
lead romantic comedy series will make
its debut on Netflix on December 21st
and we couldn't be more excited to see
what's in store for her in the big city
of Lights I just need to know are you on
my team or not I was beginning to wonder
if you were joining us at all I'm so in
on team whenever this company is called
do they know that you're pulling double
duty oh God no
and while Emily secretly pulls double
duty for both Sylvie's new agency and
her old boss Madeline her love life is
also at a Crossroads with sexy Chef
Gabriel and hot British Banker Alfie
this is the hardest decision I have ever
had to make
so Cooper
where's your head at
you changed my life
[Music]
while Emily is usually decked out in
head to toe oat Couture season 3 will
feature a more diverse range of fashion
including a number of thrift store looks
William abadi who plays Antoine in the
hit series shared with page six it's a
sign of the times to take the high-end
designers the new designers and also go
to the thrift shop and bring in Antiques
and vintage pieces it helps Elevate the
show and brings diversity in the fashion
are you all right
just some existential angst that is so
American not only will Emily be
strutting the streets of Paris and some
new ensembles but you'll also be rocking
a new do and when I spoke with Lily
earlier this month she shared how the
bold bangs were written into the show
listen Lily we gotta talk about it the
bangs Okay the bangs as I can attest to
I have changed my hair when I felt like
I've changed my life and it felt like
the perfect opportunity after getting to
know Emily season one and two so much as
who she was she's established she can
switch it up season three and it's
justifiable in the story maybe the
pressure is not worth it it's definitely
worth it it's your dream
[Music]